and we are hello everybody my name is
markiplier I'm here with Ethan and Tyler
hello we have been streaming all day for
Save the Children we've talked about it
endlessly throughout this stream but
we're here to remind you once again
actually Tyler if you could take over
and give a summary of what this cause is
all about certainly certainly save the
trevor believes that no child should be
should die from preventable causes
because hope that it's okay man been a
long day you're fine give it up no child
should die from preventable causes all
children should have access to basic
quality education and no child should be
a victim of violence and they work
everyday in times of crisis and every
day that exists in the world to meet
these three goals and they do so with
medical supplies money and supplies for
educational services and nutrition and
food and so many other things for
families and children in general and
that top left hand corner you see that
package there that will fill every $50
every $50 goes towards helping a baby
with life-saving vaccinations giving
them the nutrition both before they are
born to by giving to the mother and
after they are born and then also their
first checkup with a doctor to check
them for any diseases take care and give
them medicine if they need it it is a
huge deal and they do so many good
things last year alone they helped more
than 185 million children in 120
countries which is huge yeah it's huge
so thank you everybody that has been
with us this entire time this is the
last segment of our eight segment day of
charity livestreams we are currently
sitting pretty at a hundred and seventy
seven thousand dollars raised out of our
two hundred thousand dollar goal so
close oh oh so we're gonna play some
cards against humanity' but before we do
that I have over here with me some let
me take my phone out of my pocket here I
have two more hidden challenges that
were unlocked just in the last one alone
the last segment we did we went from one
hundred and thirty seven thousand
dollars to one hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars when we were out of
that one not a penny of which we get ten
thousand of which I've bill named myself
and every penny of which is being
doubled by an anonymous donator but for
these last two ones we've got two new
punishments here oh you only afford your
top one and I'll pull the bottom one no
why did you start with the bottom one
then Oh cuz I'm weird yeah we know but
just geez
okay whatever punk get it ah bump get it
IRL Thank You Tyler
alright thank you alright and the last
one I second to last one but now the
last one I guess is pump till you pop
what's that oh I bet you'd like to know
which one that is
yes why I asked need I remind you that I
came up with all these names cuz I
thought of them genius I know you don't
need to tell me but please do so
Punk edit IRL is as it sounds well
should we wait until we actually get the
thingies or shall we explain them now
actually we got four challenges we get
four punishments here so what we have is
Punk edit IRL where we will each be
taking turns doing live Punk edits to
each other yes yes we will pumped no
I'll save that one for later shop
collars number 20 what's that that's you
that's you that's got you all over it
what is it even jumped at you there you
go no that's mrs.six I was expecting you
to throw them at me alright this one
hurts but you're all waiting with bated
breath to find out what pump till you
pop is right right wait right that is
baited
more than ever I do dip that to get the
hair off the hair tear in my mouth well
what you're not going back in there are
you
oh we're not I know peace out with my
hands cuz I wanted to do four
punishments at once Oh
let me explain what pump do your Papa's
anyway sir pump till you pop is you have
to pump up a balloon until it pops pump
till you pop makes sense
okay so let's eat these challenges out
of the way will save Punk edit IRL for
later will do Punk till you pop Huntress
Catherine and shot-caller you get the
shock collar I'll pump till I pop and
you're hunted sound fair wait no I
thought this why all right go get the
supplies well because I am pretty much a
dictator in this spear and I have no
rules because I make up everything on
the fly everything up the bar I made up
this here in front of you I made up yes
I did
if you want to arrange the letters you
get drock's game sacks mati knew which
is my maiden name
[Laughter]
until you pop I'm pumping till I pop
excuse you all right why do you keep
eating it alright I mean hi this six you
know keeping them in the ice water
newsmakers all of us yeah don't do it
chica look chica look it's gonna blow No
that scared me so much so much so long
I'm deaf now the whole stream has died
maybe fight about to get shot you are so
remember this is the last segment that
we're doing today you were looking for
cards against humanity' and found like
this and you found the right place
because this is the one so this is the
last opportunity please if you haven't
made a donation yet please make a
donation right now we've got the list of
donators right in front of us Monica
Nora
Amanda ruck Estelle cold Josh Pratt Abby
E
thank you everybody so much for donating
we're at a hundred and seventy eight
thousand dollars which means we're just
twenty two thousand dollars it would
look away from our goal
we're so close me hey look at me panting
we're so close durable we can get there
with your help we can get there we're so
close we're so close
sync closed safety first no yes no we're
gonna get there but let's play some
cards against you man yeah where's your
shock collar right here ah there it is
get the Oh why was I the one with the
shock you came so close dating my coffee
you hush they're gonna get hit nirvan
I'm Clinton no waiting guard that you
marry come on [ __ ] you there why do I
have to get shocked I've already been
shot get my hot look
you get shot if you make a joke that's
bad objective so literally I could get
chocolate and every neither of us find
it funny are you gonna be honorable
honest is what I meant yes we will
honorably put you out of your misery bad
joke do we have up my phone's gonna die
soon so do we have a charger oh there's
God because my it's a Bluetooth operated
thing Thank You diamond hunters
Charlotte Hicks hey I'm Chris Walken
ever lady Oh Lake will.i.am anonymous
anonymous
compilation guy Stan started making
compilation of your hello everybody
thank you so much thank you oh it thank
you everybody thank you one and all for
making donations we are ready on our way
so you all remember out cards against
community works right I do I do
all right so do as everyone pick their
own or a shuffle handout oh oh they hurt
so much worse is it seventy other person
yeah I believe is seven pretty sure we
could probably go boxing pops octo
something thank you so much for the $100
donation Allison you are awesome Thank
You Cara Lauren kuroh Marie Lucia filth
or n-- thank you so much have the very
last starfish in my bank for the cause
thank you so awesome of you thank you
for sacrificing so much all right we're
gonna play who wants to go first
rock-paper-scissors yeah okay wait what
if we do what if we do a round pump and
Robin where we each do one pump and
whoever it pops on the pump of out short
or now all right we'll do rock paper
scissors rock paper scissor shoot yep
okay that's just a circle we got to redo
haha
[Laughter]
alright wait that just means I'm the
Tsar first that means I don't get a
point first right yes but I didn't want
to win that all right my first card is
and would you like those buffaloes win
and would you like those buffalo wings
mild hot or blank would you like those
buffalo wings mild hot or blank I'm not
looking I'm not looking
no I'm not from skiers no I'm Miranda
right yeah Rando oh dude I'm gonna eat
the sharp be on this out of hold on the
curtain we're ready for your head go
ahead no knees yes make sure you alright
and would you like those buffalo wings
mild hot or mooing and would you like
those buffalo wings mild hot or touching
a pug right on his penis would you like
those buffalo wings mild hot or whining
like a little [ __ ]
why did look a little [ __ ] I don't want
wings that are whining like a little
[ __ ] though but I don't want wings or
I'll go with whiningly a little [ __ ]
yeah alright there you go which one was
yours was some latina see oh that was
Brando Brando Brando pretty bugger it
was wink back go get him no I don't have
your power joke what
mooing was pretty bad oh my back he's
waited by his heart
Thank You Jared Quinn not for $100 thank
you
ninja wizard with $50 copy 5000 are made
out of chicken didn't think I'd get shot
you're I'm sorry sir but we don't allow
blank at the Country Club
oh I'm sorry Dunlap no you're good
you're a good chicken
you got a pass you were doing so good
they're so good today so good
are you guys ready no why are you
messing with my cards Vargas with $100
and Ellora with $50 well and at
belladonna neighbor with $20 all right
uh wait hang on oh okay
back to petting chica all right we're
ready they're in no particular order
not those doesn't mine why are there
more than three I'm sorry sir but we
don't allow a man in yoga pants with a
ponytail and feather earrings at the
Country Club I'm sorry sir but we don't
allow the wrath of Vladimir Putin at the
Country Club I'm sorry sir but we don't
allow the patriarchy at the Country Club
I'm sorry sir but we don't like a
disappointing salad at the Country Club
well those are bad
patriarchy that's me German thank you
all right we're there for and what were
you conspiring as I heard whispered that
was nothing lies you're paranoid
Hey the Japanese have developed a
smaller one if you take off your shock
collar oh no I was gonna put it on once
I needed to you need well we can't shock
him because it's fun stretch oh yeah the
Japanese have developed a smaller more
efficient version of blank okay all
right go for it
please this is murder the Japanese have
developed a smaller more efficient
version of being on fire a smaller more
efficient version of a greased up
Matthew McConaughey the Japanese have
developed a smaller more efficient
version of exist good stuff all right
man this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] blank Matt this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
blank
[Laughter]
good wall hmm good wall well it's a good
wall it's not that funny go ahead mark
you're ready all right you're cackling
at your own joke no better to laugh man
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] soup is too hot my
god shoot that's not my card [ __ ]
[ __ ] the American dream man is [ __ ]
[ __ ] the human body man is [ __ ] bye
is that like that or is that like not
like that it's up for interpretation
I'll go a soup was that Rando that must
been Rando yeah human body we are you
laughed at the human body I did but I
didn't know which way it was supposed to
go and I interpreted it with confusion
just like an interpret everything in
life okay
it lurks in the night and hookers for
flesh the summer no one is safe for
bling this summer noise is safe from
don't know if you could hear through
that accident
alright go ahead do it this summer no
innocent Emily Rose with $50 Abbi
berries $50 grace with 20 Emily we're at
a hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars pretty much very close we're so
close to our goal close at 17-thousand
away oh and Jared Quinet I've sold bonds
whoa Tara connect with a hundred K okay
yeah I'll give $100 anybody that does
this name can do Jarrett right all right
go for it no one is safe from my paws on
your face no one is safe from sexual
tension and no one is safe from the
gulags balls goddamn that darn thing
howl like Joseph spins with 150 dollar a
spin how will I keep the peasants in
line
Go Go honey
Lily Booga Rini $20 carry nerdy gamer
tabs Kristin Ackerman jr. Oh Alec damron
Maddy yawns thank you everybody for for
donating asking how will I keep the
peasants in line Panda sex
syphilitic insanity sorry I took a
second however much weed $20 and buy I
guess panda sex all right
you are not alone millions of America's
struggle Americans struggle with blank
every day you're not alone millions of
Americans struggle and blank every day
go ahead mister all right you're not
alone millions of Americans struggle
with tiny nipples every day you're not
alone millions of Americans struggle
with Bill Clinton naked on a bearskin
rug with a saxophone every day you're
not alone millions of Americans struggle
at the KKK every day with tiny nipples
oh sure okay all right it's that woo or
whoo whoo god damn I love blink
you're good
god damn I love not wearing pants Oh
goddamn I love brain the Gateway well
goddamn I love Mufasa is death scene you
gotta be death scene yeah yeah when he
went all like brother or no brother no
voiced by Hulk Hogan I love to hold
Hogan in the Lion King would be pretty
good I have a strict policy first date
dinner second date yes sir date
okay all right with God go go just go
I have a strict policy first date dinner
second dig kiss third date getting
really high second date kiss their date
finger painting
[Laughter]
finger painting is really funny I guess
the placenta damn pen I really liked
thanks man one of my cards I don't know
I'd be impressed with sometimes on what
your finger painting was right
[Laughter]
my grandfather worked his way up for
nothing when he came to this country all
he had was his shoes on his feet and
blank my grandfather worked his way up
from nothing
oops wait which one of these is mine
these are my didn't wait no hang on one
of those is ran these are mine that's
ran though okay all right my grandpa
Hogan away I don't want to get into the
country all yellow shoes of Sweden Blanc
whoa yeah thank you thank you so much ah
are you ready okay yeah what do we got
my grandfather what my grandfather
worked my grandfather away Dempsey's way
from the other thing when he can't do
the times we all he had with his shoes
on his feet and a cooler full of organs
a cooler full of the wardens old people
smell all he had was a shoes on his feet
and strong female characters I can't go
strong female characters you gotta well
you know you know but okay I mean I
think it's you know no no no I forget
humanity it is cards games manager yeah
there's no limits all right you good all
right don't worry kid it gets better
I've been living with AIDS for 20 years
don't worry kid it gets better I've been
living with hospice care for 20 years
don't worry kid it gets better I've been
living with cuddling for 20 years AIDS
[Laughter]
my gym teacher got fired for adding
bling to the obstacle course
you're good
that was fast hey we're fast people my
gym teacher got fired for adding poor
people to the obstacle course
i Jim teacher got fired for adding
catapults the obstacle course my gym
teacher got fired for adding pictures of
boobs to the obstacle course yes yes
poor people Sophia thank you for the $20
sorry for the 40 Kaitlin be Anderson for
the $20 thank you so much and anonymous
with ten dollars twice
we're at 80 a hundred and eighty-six
thousand dollars fourteen thousand away
from our goal oh heck yeah we're gonna
hit that near to Ivy also with $30 all
right in the seventh circle of hell
sinners must endure blank for all
eternity
go ahead okay in the seventh circle of
hell sinners must endure Scientology for
all eternity sinners must endure getting
married having a few kids buying some
stuff or tying to Florida and dying
we're all in dirty sinners must enjoy
some goddamn peace and quiet for all
eternity
yeah ah damn it I mean I guess it's okay
not this [ __ ] I'm not like the rest
of you I'm too rich and too busy for
blink I'm too rich and too busy for jobs
too rich and too busy for the hustle and
too busy and too too rich and too busy
for sunshine and rainbows jobs yeah damn
can I get rid of my cards you can trade
on all of your cards and get new cards
or however that is a thank you yeah it's
supposed to substitute a time if you do
it against humanity well you know this
well I'll just do it once okay that's
fine just once all right that seems fair
the only two things in life only two
things in life are certain death and
Jesus already I don't know man you
haven't even seen it
and just full of get over there yeah mmm
good the thing is like I want to kind of
like weed out the bad ones first okay
where they going here yeah that's about
okay all right you're good right there
here only two things in life are certain
death and wiping her but only two things
in life are certain death who's but her
but like all those bumper stickers I see
that I stand with her is that the her
yes but only two things of life certain
death and third base only two things in
life are certain death and licking
things to claim them as your own does
likewise my country tis of thee sweet
land of and I will be singing
the
go okay all right
just do this right now edge just once
all right okay my country tis of thee
sweet land of demonic possession my
country tis of thee sweet land of Ronald
Reagan my sweet little super superval
cat pee
I got a goin that one cuz it rhyme have
anything that rhymed
I played Ronald Reagan I was hoping
you'd go Reagan II oh you guys know oh
good old Reagan II Ronald Reagan II mix
you know I feel like you could end all
of the ones to Rand oh sure the healing
process began when I joined a support
group for the victims of blank
Oh whatever you do whatever you want man
you do whatever you want I just don't
have rules here I guess wait I don't
know isn't done I thought I heard
[Laughter]
process again when I joined a support
group for the victims of poopie diapers
for the victims of God for the victims
of a really cool head puppy diapers god
damn it literally god damn it all right
tsa guidelines now prohibit blink on
airplanes I go oh come on
real estate guidelines now prohibit a
pangender octopus who roams the cosmos
in search of love on airplanes tsa
guidelines uh prohibit Tom Cruise on
airplanes now prohibit completely
unwarranted confidence on airplanes hmm
where's the octopus the octopus travel
everywhere if you can't get on planes
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
illegally happy charades was ruined for
me forever when my mom had to act out
blank all right come on mr. funny man
tell me what happens over there giggles
come on come on chuckles okay all right
all right all right charades was ruined
for me for everyone my mom had to act
out unfathomable stupidity ha I'm not
yours oh okay all right then she raised
was ruined for me forever when my mom
had to act out sperm whales races run
forever when my mom and act out anal
beads which one of these fraught with
hilarious cards could I pick from the
choice is so complex and go a sperm
whale I guess yeah
[Laughter]
Thank You G Ravens on 400 and end of
this a bit more we've got Monica passer
with $100 whoa yeah and everybody that's
been donating more on our lazy maniac
board Tyler didn't cozy Mackenzie's dorm
of shadows beater Jones thank you
everybody
we're at 187 thousand dollars we are
just about twelve thousand dollars away
from our goal to make it we're gonna
make it keep it up what again never save
this for the last thing we pop my cards
waiting out there in my pocket
introducing extreme baseball it's like
baseball but with blank that's when you
play dream baseball no one even heard
what you said it's like baseball
[Laughter]
baseball it's like baseball but with
civilian casualties extreme baseball
it's like baseball but with friends how
I'm maintaining my relationship status
[Music]
only when they can think of is that or
this we've all done it I know I'm saving
it - all right all right you good get
out there how am i maintaining my
relationship status of becoming a
blueberry
oh my room maintaining my relationship
status Count Chocula how am i
maintaining my relationship status
breaking out into song and dance well
they're all bad
I guess becoming a blueberry yeah got
him got him got him got him got him got
him instead of cold Santa now gives the
bad children whoa let me avert my eyes
of the genius with just before you know
maybe I should mix this all right okay
Santa instead of coal Santa now gives
the bad children dead behavior stop box
for skin Santa know instead of coal
Santa now gives the bad children should
mr. for mrs. chicken white people like
blank people like blink
go ahead all right good
white people like the wonders of the
Orient white people like a fetus white
people like drinking alone the class
field trip was completely ruined by the
class field trip was completely ruined
by a condom whoa
warden 53 with 1111 dollars and 11 cents
what and then Caroline would $500 Oh
warden 53 there's a red one right there
who's sir give me a good warden warden
you're the one anonymous with eight
dollars $20 Nicole wood 15 Emily Rose
with dollar 69 we love you warden warden
and who was the other one
Caroline Caroline ba ba ba but you never
here thank you
long everybody sings it to my I bet I
bet you're on subscribe right now all
right sorry
the class field trip was completely
ruined by a defective condom was
completely ruined by Italians thank you
but I need to explain cuz they just
imagined like just a bunch of berries on
the shaded colleges like over the hill
just like a mob of them but not like a
mob mob just like a bunch of I've ever
seen say is the Sylvester Stallone in
Rocky this is the teachers looking over
like how to smile and having a good day
looks over the horizon they're just like
all the color dressed alone in
sunglasses alright who's my yeah alright
cool
alright what never fails to liven up a
party what never fails to liven up a
party I'll tell you it's holding down a
child and farting all over what never
Dale is alive enough of already classist
undertones whatever fails alive and up a
party 1000 slim jims okay so here's my
conundrum one of these is funnier than
the other I'm picking that one pains me
out to be a terrible person pick the
farty we only got two more two more two
more help me doctor
I've got blank in my go for it I'm good
I'm a doctor I've got concealing a boner
but help me doctor I've got horse meat
in my butt horse meat that's me it was a
little funny
alright last one last one finally a
service that delivers blank right to
your door hmm how many carts are here
oh really I don't know guys are awful I
know what's over this are you guys
looking through every card no no no no
no well if you are I'm gonna go to the
bathroom
what no well it's gotta happen sooner or
later
how long a little bit hold it
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then we got a pic from ours I don't
know man no shoe sheer face you should
have gone what about that 30 minute
break that we had I obviously didn't
have to go then wait didn't you take a
shower before this finally a service the
delivers fun coming traffic right to a
service that delivers a giant powdery
man-baby right to your door a service
delivery service that delivers vigorous
gas hands right to your door a service
that delivers a live studio audience
right to your door and a service that
delivers a pinata full of scorpions
right to your door yeast 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
[Music]
the tiebreaker round is donations
there's not 300 know you can have a tail
again oh you go all right all right
we've got just 10 minutes in our
normally scheduled time and we've got
$6,000 left to raise we can do this so
let's read name sinto let's read names
as we go you go stand and pressed $60
Remi ramp
Reimer $30 mckenna call $50 mr. poopy
butt $20 Kirra Berryman $5 Jase which $1
jeweled your $5 charissa $5 yeah if you
guys haven't donate
we are slowly bein clear again at over
69 weird about two trillion starlight
again $1 $200,000 raised in just about
Chelsea horsy on screen time that is
better than we've never done before
history of my charity livestreams like
we've raised more money through dollar
amounts and through like whoa tell $120
officially the last one of that
Avni wait where's that yeah Avni got you
right there thank you so much $2 you are
great 23:37 fill ski $5 Kelly battery
Tyler I hope you get that virtual hug I
sent you during something $20 Marisa may
BA $5
you guys are absolutely awesome thank
you so much for being a part of this if
you haven't made a donation yet look in
the description there's total to five
calm slash at markiplier it is such an
easy resource for you to be able to make
these donations it's so simple for you
to go there whenever you can make a
donation through PayPal please consider
making a donation it goes a long way we
are 6,000 less than seven pounds if you
know a way to get from our goal which
means that we are about to actually
raise $400,000 which means we are about
to raise $400,000 because everything
that is being donated right now is being
matched how'd it go xisa below $100 a
ball with $100 Oh
so please give whatever you can this is
the last stress that we have here it
means the most right now because what I
want to see what happens when we hit
200,000 of Manliness see something big
and amazing happens when we hit $200,000
we are so unbelievably close if you
haven't given it and I know there's
people out there that have not given
that still can clean up some of our $150
there's 38 how many people are in this
stream click on over on the analytics
let's see how many people are in this
stream right now there's 38,000 people
and if you're right now you know what
that is that's that's a starfish if each
person you know that's 50 cents per
person yeah
that's 50 cents per person less less
than fifth that's like 40 cents per
person
but the minimum donation until tafoya's
one day stash is bringing it up with
$200
Crossgate with $100 Rick Rick Rick coos
girl anonymous puffle wolf Alissa Amanda
Megan Starks Amanda G saya anonymous
with $30.00 Christine Katrina Hansen ten
dollars number one uno donated 1.5 k you
mean number one uno all right
tip number one who know donate again
because if number one who know did you
are absolutely unbelievable Brittany be
anonymous care and graceful water
buffalo oh good Emily Rose bogan Dana J
$5 ain't sking with 20 or sorry the gays
with 20 dave fondle with 50 let chica
eat steak Alice booze in de faria jack
ver HOF menagerie Darrell Evans Tristan
burner Jenna banana with another
donation total of 45 Rihanna's ooh be
good three with $40 rice come his trash
with $3 Janelle Anna Todd and in a
metric $10 starfish Quintin Nikki mark
with $150 not me how'd you do anything
didn't do that Lizzy loose soul $20
Chanel Ashley
Tom's one coffee Grady Joslin Mitchell
gobble olives mom sir cold ski Sarah
Eaton Kellen Stinnett with $20 Farrah's
181 turkey Tyler Ariel hardly gardener
Kira sparks Emily note and Clare Jim
Nick Kalman Roma she with all hundred
dollars Rachel Draper with $300 Pat art
Elijah you know Sylvestre Marissa Crowe
everybody please keep giving we're at a
hundred and ninety seven thousand five
and ago oh my gosh we're so close so
close the hundred dollar donation is
easy $50 notice we've got five minutes
left to hit this goal we can Austin
Jacob Quentin Dara C with fifteen
dollars donated spooky dextersen el
profesor saver if this stream made you
laugh if you had fun today if you had a
great time
if you had any fun at all no we're
donating our time I donated my
money we don't make anything hundred
dollars again Martian princess oh yeah
has a Phoebe Chang 98 I'm dying inside
David Shelby patch 1 C 3 fo x vortex
with $100 donation skid space eats T bug
Kyra Lady Lake Emeralds s Gruen Jordan
Sierra snow life tone shift Luke Lazarus
tone shifts gave $1 in 101 11 cents I
give more but I don't have any more
that's fine amazing captain mica
ungraceful something $10 of blab minute
donations the gyms Jake flunked CJ
Andrew Caldwell Sadie Shelby Amy garden
with $100 glory Dan the Duke amber Haley
real ldk d random summer Ali and Lila
Tessa slightly used a be something
Michelle oh babe am with $10 win Adam
mega Rachel Palo Samantha gone something
Kelsey hat Bunga palace Andy add me
Patel you said you were done Avenue
you've done your part and more thank you
so much nila $50 Hilario Nick row bunny
Mallory Bonnie Melina we have a new card
it's atomic a I inhale my dong
page 18 s Witek kiss me mark
Silvia Olivia Oliver Jack Donald Gerald
$700 in a carry at least anonymous Nancy
James carry Richard come on Beachwood
this let's go asylum
amber Geneva something Louis Marilla the
non-magical blank Aaron lucky Yoshi
anonymous lethal Nestor last one night
what's good David burrows Lauren sparse
nugget with $2,500 les Oh Alex Walker
Emma I love you people ran to burn with
$50.00 love you shocked Ethan two
dollars Mia Anderson we got a shock you
before the enjoy no under Lord Kaelin
Thompson Ethan's girlfriend to a hundred
dollars total day James channel 20 goes
David Chen $5.00 carry hundreds left Joe
Jordan Rea real LDK
so what I've been told is at 200,000 the
match is gonna be donated right now whoa
whenever they are able to do it tilts if
is gonna transmit the wire transfer
straight in if tilted by 200,000 is
about to be donated from our anonymous
matching now we're already at almost two
hundred and one thousand we have to
watch alright I just want to say while
we're waiting for this
thank you everybody that is contributed
this match is an incredible amount and
it's super amazing to see that we could
have come this far because I never
thought from pure monetary donations
reaching two hundred thousand dollars I
never would have imagined that but we
did it because not only like did we band
together and not only did we plan this
and have fun but you guys dug so deep
unbelievably deep like we were trending
number one on tumblr just because of how
many people were sharing and posting
about fun moments from the stream we
were talking to everybody like we're
just in a confetti party right now you
guys spread so far more powerful than
anything else on the Internet at that
particular time today like we just took
over everything in a wave of goodwill
and you guys should be so proud of what
you've done there were a lot of people
that like when we started this out or
when I told people that we added 200,000
gold last night
people are like oh now that'll never
happen but you did it we didn't even
like we didn't even stress like the time
limit we didn't even stretch it you guys
are going beyond that these are
donations that were already there we're
at 202 thousand dollars waiting for a
two hundred thousand dollar bomb to come
through wait oh it's might just be on
the board I mean GLAAD will show off on
the new name Oh
celebrate now you don't need to see it
it's right there wait oh four hundred
thousand dollars four hundred thousand
two thousand dollars we uh we were not
lying
four hundred and two thousand dollars
straight from your contributions of
generosity you're amazing like will to
share your amazing efforts in trying to
go out there and and you can see that
this wasn't for nothing
this was for something incredible and
not every stream are we gonna be able to
have an anonymous donor that's gonna be
matching what we do but god damn you
guys should be so proud of yourselves
for what you've done here like tell the
word brag about this seriously honestly
brag about that how you were a part of
this moment where we raised four hundred
and three thousand dollars for Save the
Children and that's gonna mean so much
for everybody around the world kids
across the globe are gonna have so much
families just needs met like that is an
insane amount of money that's going to
such an incredible cause and like I'm in
awe at what like what's happened just
now yeah and you guys should be too I'm
really proud of you guys
I just want to say thank you from the
bottom of my heart for making this
something incredibly special
you guys should celebrate this moment
cuz again we don't touch any of this
money so there's nothing for us to
handle it's already at save the children
like it's already been contributed like
like we don't even see it yeah other
than the number the numbering we don't
see any of it at all yeah like it's good
I'm sorry go no carry on like I know
today we've been talking about like we
got to hit this two-hundred thousand
dollar goal because we have someone
that's matching it which is awesome and
it's so amazing that someone was
generous enough to match up to two
hundred thousand dollars it's incredible
but on its own raising two hundred
thousand dollars in 12 hours that
absolutely insane like that is totally
totally insane like thanking batsmen 12
oh yeah and a half hours it's crazy like
the first charity stream that you ever
did do you didn't even race like $1000
24 hours it's in 24 hours yeah it's it's
just so insane what we can do as a
community because again this would not
even be close to possible without you
guys you guys did all of this like sure
we're the ones that have the stream
going but you guys are the ones that are
contributing your time and your money
and and all of your shares and
everything to make this happen none of
this would have happened without you
guys it is a hundred percent used so
thank you guys so much for coming to the
streams everyone and donating your time
and your money to such amazing causes
and thank you guys for proving everybody
who doubted all of this wrong you know
there's so many people out there that
are like oh yeah there's no way that
they can raise that much money and we
did it and we did it and that's like
such a great feeling not only are we
raising money for such an amazing cause
but it also we're just proving to people
that like we can accomplish these goals
that we set for ourselves and it's so so
awesome I'm so incredibly proud of you
guys thank you guys so much for being
here
and thank you again just for just for
just for coming and donating your money
it's so amazing and it's gonna go to
such a great cause and there's gonna be
so many children that are going to have
improved lives because of you guys like
you guys are literally saving children's
lives today so thank you so much
so according to Save the Children
statistics it takes an average of $5 for
Save the Children to change the course
of a child's future those packages you
see in the top corner that's 8,000
packages at 400 thousand dollars that's
eight thousand packages for like just
one infant one child that is born the
impact that made just saving their life
potentially the not to mention like the
five dollars I can't do the math right
now but four hundred thousand dollars
divided by five is
it's an immense amount of kids that are
gonna be affected by this just from this
12-hour span and your contributions
alone has impacted so many people across
the world over 120 countries that Save
the Children works in like I I have no
other way to explain it just other than
what's on this sheet like the amount of
good that this community has done in the
last 12 hours not even 12 hours has made
one of the biggest impacts I have ever
visually seen and been a part of in my
entire life like this is huge this is
like I I don't even know how to put in
the words how I'm feeling right now
because I sat there and I'm like alright
200-thousand this is more than we've
ever done more like together let alone
like mark by himself when he was doing
charity livestreams in the past like
this is huge we did this without like
merch sales contributing like we had the
leftover shirts that were sent out and
that's insane that's something that's
really cool because like having having
the charity merch and stuff it is is
awesome
and it's cool that like part of the part
of the donation goes to the charity and
then you also get a cool shirt out of it
but it's just like it just shows even
more how much you guys care because you
guys are literally just giving your
money with nothing in return you guys
expect nothing in return and all you
guys want to do is just help make a
difference and that's really really
awesome and you know not only is it
affecting all of those children who
you're saving their life but also their
families too because I can't imagine
what those families are going through
and you guys have helped out those
families so much you know like having
having to be a parent and seeing that
your child may not live and then just
having some of that stress relieved
because of Save the Children like you
guys are helping so many parents
and so many kids brothers and sisters
and aunts and uncles and just all their
families so so so so much so thank you
guys again and we're almost at four 4015
we're at $14 this is astonishing of what
people's continued generosity does and I
want you guys to remember this moment to
be perfectly honest I want you guys to
remember this moment for years to come
because these are the special moments to
come along we're gonna continue doing
charity events we're gonna continue
asking guys to help out and be a part of
these campaigns but first and foremost I
want you guys to take a moment and just
be proud of what you've done because
it's like Ethan said it's like I tweeted
out a while ago there's gonna be people
that'll tell you that you can't or that
you shouldn't or that you won't or that
you're trying like for something that'll
never happen
and all you have to do is prove them
wrong because that's all that matters in
the end of it is you taking life and
just saying that I want to make a
difference and I don't care who gets in
my way I'm gonna do it anyway and
cumulatively that leads to four hundred
and fifteen thousand dollars and
Counting going to saving children's
lives so from all of us here I'm gonna
just
I think we've I think we've worded
enough so I just want to say a very
heartfelt thank you to Ethan for being
with me for Tyler for number one like
organizing this and bringing this
charity about and telling me that there
was someone that was gonna be
contributing two hundred thousand
dollars a lot of what you see in the
charity that we picked here is because
of Tyler I want to thank Evan on camera
I want to thank Amy for running all the
behind the scenes stuff and helping run
things around Katherine who's been at
Maine control pretty much the entire
time running the sound and they're
calling the shots for the cameras and
first and foremost thank you every
single one of you for trying out this
little experimental way of doing live
streams and really embracing it sharing
the silly moments and I really hope you
share the loving moments too because the
so many good memories to be had from
this day that I'm gonna remember for a
long time because when I say that I
remember these things down the road this
day five years from now is probably one
of the special ones so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we will see you in the next video
bye bye thank you so much thank